But we're just wondering why you guys
hate the Quran. Bro,
>> I love the Quran. It's the word of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala.
>> You cherish the Quran.
>> We love it, man. Where do you get the
idea from?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Where do you get the idea from? We We
don't love it.
>> Life, where do we get this idea from
that Muslims don't love the Quran?
>> From Muslims. [laughter]
>> From Muslims. From the mumon, man. F.
Hey, first eyewitness accounts,
>> right?
>> We get it from the eyewitnesses. Y'all
don't like to [laughter] grow. Give it
about 10 minutes, we may hear it from
the Muslims, man.
>> And you guys should do like a comedy
skit.
>> Thanks, bro.
>> Hey, featuring the Muslims. As long as
we got a Muslim on stage, the right
Friday night entertainment.
>> I love that, man. I love that. So, uh,
so Nas, man, and in in our experience,
when we read the Quran to a lot of
Muslims, they tend to reject what we
read. They tend to manipulate it or
twist it somehow and they just don't
accept what the Quran says.
>> Why do you think that is?
>> I mean I can't speak for everyone but
>> could be like you know lack of
knowledge, understanding something you
know takes you by surprise.
>> Okay. Instead of so instead of you know
saying okay I might not know let me go
do some research. Most of them say
something crazy that visually throw the
whole Quran under the bus. Why do you
think that? Why do you think that is a
consistent theme in these live streams
and in these discussions between Jews I
mean between Christians and Muslims?
>> Between Jews and Muslims.
>> Jews and Muslims.
>> Yeah. [laughter] It looks like you're in
the hot seat there.
>> Yeah. I think I think if when your when
your belief system and your faith is
like under the scanner or under attack,
then like naturally, you know,
defensive, you go into that defensive
mode and it's either like fight or
flight mode. But yeah, I know you're
right. Yeah, you you need to like
obviously it's it's actually a good
reminder like watching your streams,
it's helped me actually like learn more
and like look more into my religion and
scriptures and get a better
understanding of it to you know try and
defend it better or you know put it
forward in a in a positive light. So no
are you think of science, right?
>> Are you or team Allah?
>> Yeah, I definitely follow, you know,
Allah and Well, yeah, follow the andah.
Yeah. So the book of Allah and
>> Amen. You on our team, brother.
>> You on our team, man.
>> Why you not Muslim then?
>> Cuz you on you just on the wrong side.
You on the right team. You just on the
wrong side. That's all. My my my B my B
my B. That was my
>> Logic doing rookie.
>> My B
>> like for for for example um N do you
think Allah can have a son?
>> He he can he can do whatever he wills.
>> He can do whatever he wills.
>> It's not befitting of his majesty.
>> What like what does he say that at?
>> Uh yeah surah buruj chapter of the
constellations.
You know he does what he wishes or
intends. Yeah. Surah Buru is one of the
later suras the constellations like a
short sura but yeah clearly stays in
there that he does what he wills
>> I'm not saying what he did I'm just
asking could he
>> yeah that's what I drive from that
>> right does he need a mate to do so
>> or can he do it on his own
>> he doesn't need anyone but there's but
there's no one but then that that was
that would go against his essence of
being alah the one Nah, according to
Allah. Logic, drop that drum roll.
>> Good.
>> According to Allah, he needs a mate to
have a son. He needs a consort. So, he
can't do it on his own.
>> You agree?
>> He can do anything he wishes on his own.
>> Why do you hate your Quran?
>> Yeah, that's you proving the point right
here.
>> There's context to that verse. The cont
the context of the verse is that they're
saying that he has the son and Allah's
refuting them by saying how can I have a
son when I don't have a mate.
>> So does he need a mate?
>> Yeah he's addressing humans and he's
putting in their in their you know in
their vernacular in their like he's
giving like he's striking example for
them
>> right but is it conveying the truth
about Allah
>> and it's like a pure hypothetical
which never will like manifest.
>> Can hypotheticals be true?
Yes.
>> Okay. Yes, they can. So, even if this is
a hypothetical,
>> logic,
>> logic can't save you. He's on team a
lot.
>> To reality or true in terms of just
logic
>> to to reality.
>> Like if I say if I get hungry, if I get
hungry, I'm going to go to the
>> grocery store and buy me some food. It's
a hypothetical, but it could be reality
because if I get hungry, I'm going to go
to the food, I mean to the grocery store
and get some food. Hypothetical. That's
true in reality.
>> False equivalence because you're a
human. You have need for food to
survive. So,
>> no, I'm just g that was just analogy I
was giving you.
>> Okay. I'm saying
>> I need food. I need food to to survive.
This is why this is equivalent. Allah
needs a mate to have a son. That's why
it's equivalent.
>> He he says in also in like another verse
where if he were to, you know, take a
son, then you know, Prophet Muhammad was
he'll be the first one to worship him.
And like I said, like the other verse I
mentioned earlier from the
constellations, he will, you know, he
can he he does whatever he wills. And
this specific example you're bringing
up,
>> I know, but
>> this specific example you're bringing
up, he's basically putting in human
vernacular.
>> Okay. But but we're saying you said this
is a hypothetical even though we already
established that hypotheticals can be
true. And if Allah is using terms in
their [clears throat] vernacular,
I like that word you just used.
>> I like that that word vernacular. He's
still conveying the truth about himself.
>> No, no, he's he's rationalizing it for
for for the ignorant people he's
addressing in that verse.
>> Yeah, we agree.
>> Worshippers.
>> Yeah, we we agree. That's what he's
doing. But he's still conveying the
truth about himself.
>> Can we agree?
>> That's like saying that's like saying if
God wishes to die or like ceases to
exist, can he do that?
>> No, that's not the same.
>> It, you know, it it goes against his
essence. It It goes against his
>> It doesn't because he said if he wanted
a son, he would have to get a mate.
>> He states in the Quran.
He's the one. He's the one states in the
Quran. You hate your
>> I ain't got no I ain't got no
>> I love my Quran but yo you're like
you're just playing like you know
devilish and like twisting it in some
weird bizarre way
proving exactly what we said earlier.
>> Congratulations Naz. You hate the Quran.
>> You hate the Quran man.
>> You just don't win to team Yahwa just
like that.
>> You said you was on team Allah and we
believed you. Couple of questions. Two
questions.
>> No way. You went back to team dawa. Come
on back to team Allah. Believe what
Allah says. So,
>> all right. There's a there's a delay.
Naz,
>> that question that question is a
>> you got too much of a delay, man.
>> It's it's it's slowing down the
conversation.
>> You're a good sport, though.
>> My bad.
>> It's okay, man. When you used to come
up, you used to have used your internet
was fine. But, uh, if you could fix that
and try to come back up, that would be
cool, man. But, try to try to get that
together because the past two times
you're you've had a delay. Ah,
[clears throat] but all right. Uh, so
one Muslim down that hates his Quran.
Man, that's tough. One Muslim down that
hates his Quran. You're Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Why do you guys hate your Quran, man?
>> I don't hate the Quran.
>> Yeah. Why do you hate it? How?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, when we read from the Quran, you
don't accept what it says.
>> How?
>> Well, we'll read to you a verse. For
example, like um like for example, life.
Do you have an example for him? Can you
hear me from here? Yeah, we can. Oh, no.
Um, Tik Tok
>> Mike is chopped as his arguments.
Definitely.
>> So, you said that you uh you love the
Quran?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you cherish it?
>> You would never reject the Quran or what
it says?
>> Of course not.
>> Okay. So, when the Quran says, for
example, that um that the previous
scriptures is the authority over the
Quran, you accept that
>> words explicitly state that.
>> It doesn't have to be explicit in those
exact words. But if it teaches that or
it says it, then it
>> just said it states that it's an
authority upon it. On contrary, the
Quran declares it authority on the
previous scriptures.
>> No, it doesn't. All right. Um, yeah. So,
>> you want to see where it does that?
>> Not yet.
>> Negative. Not yet. Not yet. Cuz you said
my arguments.
>> You said no, it doesn't.
>> Not yet. I said not yet. You said my
arguments
says it's a it's a
>> Not yet. You said my arguments were
dumb. Slow down. Let's hear your
arguments.
>> All right. For sure. Yeah, my mic is
good now. Yeah, my mic is good now.
Okay. Uh oh. Uh oh.
>> All right. So, let's So, let's check it
out. Let's chop. Let's check it out.
Let's see if
you're panicking already.
>> Let's go to Let's go.
>> As soon as I As soon as I got soon as I
got my mic up, you started panicking.
You see this?
>> I'm I'm panicking, bro.
>> Cuz you won't stop talking over me.
>> Yeah, because you won't stop talking.
>> You made a claim.
>> I said I said I said,
>> "Should we get the next guest?"
>> Hope we probably We probably need to.
He's He's panicking. Can't control
himself.
>> He's already chanick. He doesn't he
doesn't want to be questioned. He think
he heard something. Let's read
>> and now he
do you not consider those who were given
a portion of this debating shut man.
Shut your dumb mouth again off the stage
manate the dude is debating. Dude is
debating himself. What an embarrassment.
>> Guys, we're asking for human beings.
Normal human beings, not robots that are
malfunctioning. Please
Muslim, y'all.
>> Khalifo. All right, we're going to try
one more. What happens y'all? Muslims
debate themselves and think they won.
Man, he clearly won. I don't know about
you, but I was convinced. Come to Islam
TV.
>> Good evening.
>> Good evening, man. Do you hate your
Quran?
>> Why do Muslim eat the Quran?
>> How do we eat the Quran?
>> Yeah. You don't accept the verses. You
don't you don't respect what the verses
say. You don't believe it. You don't
follow what Allah tells you to follow.
>> I follow whatever I see in the Quran.
>> You do?
>> The way Allah permitted us to follow it.
>> All right. Cool. So in chapter 2:es 2-5,
it tells you that you have to believe in
the Torah and the Injil in order to be
successful and rightfully guided by
Allah. Do you do that?
>> Yes, you do.
>> Yes, I did.
>> Where's the Torah and the you where's
the Torah and the Injil you believe in?
>> When you believe something, it means
that it's not by first to see it before
you believe. We believe in it because we
did not see itself.
>> So you believe in it because you've
never seen it.
>> Yes. So [snorts] I believe in
>> Yeah. So Okay. So Okay. So when he says
believe in the Quran also that means
that you can believe in the Quran
without ever seeing it. Right?
>> If No, I have to see the Quran because
Allah commanded me to follow the Quran.
So he never commanded.
>> Yeah. He also commanded you he also
commanded you to follow everything he
revealed. So that would mean the Quran
and everything. He never said he never
said so.
>> So he never said so. All right. Give me
give me give me give me uh give me uh
>> where he says that I should follow
whatever he refused in the past.
>> Yeah. Chapter 4 136.
>> Okay. Chapter 4 verse 636.
>> Yeah. Read it out loud, too.
>> Wait, wait.
>> Read it out loud.
>> Get the verse. 132, right?
>> 4 436.
>> Okay. 136.
>> I believe. So, if it's not it, then it's
in four though. It says, "Oh, who have
believe in Allah and his messenger and
the book that he sent down upon his
messenger and the scripture which is
sent down before and whoever disbelieve
in Allah, his messenger, his angels, his
books, his messengers on the last day,
>> his what?"
>> And certainly gone far afraid.
>> His books plural, right? Two books,
right? Multiple book multiple books,
right? Yes.
>> Oh, is to believe, not so he did tell
you to believe in all the books.
>> Hey man, here you go. Life,
>> we are to [laughter] we are to believe
them, not to follow them. What is
difference between believe?
>> Brother, it just said believe in all of
his books, bro. Stop lying. Come on,
man.
>> Yes, I
>> I thought you didn't I thought you I
thought you didn't hate your Quran.
>> How do I hate my Quran?
>> Because you're not You said you believe
You said you do everything your book
tells you.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. Your book tells you to believe in
all of Allah's books.
>> I believe in them.
>> Okay. Where are the books that you
believe in?
>> I believe Allah sent some books to the
prophets. It's not by look for them,
>> brother. He tells you to believe in
them. You have to look for them.
>> Okay. Wait, wait. Now I I have to
believe that
Bameu is our is our president in
Nigeria. Have I ever seen him face to
face? I believe he's our prophet. is our
president.
>> Brother, where are the books that you
believe in? It's either you have them or
you don't.
>> I told you to to believe is different
from to follow. Those books are are for
those people who receive the books, not
us. We are just to believe that they are
from God.
>> It where does it say that?
>> Give me the verse.
>> Give me the verse. Where does it say
that?
>> That says what? Where does it say just
believe that the other books are from
God while believing in the Quran means
that you have to believe in the actual
physical book? Where does it say that?
>> Allah Allah told us to follow the
messenger and the message.
>> And what does the messenger right and
what does the messenger tell you to do?
Follow all of his books.
>> No, he never says so.
>> Brother, you just you What do you mean
give you the verse? You just read it.
>> It It says we should believe, not to
follow. Uhuh.
So I can believe in the Quran without
following the Quran.
>> If you you can believe it, it's from
Allah and you should not follow it. That
is your cup of tea.
>> The only way that I can believe that the
Quran The only way I can believe the
Quran is from Allah. Allah
>> is if I follow the if if I follow the
information revealed within it, right?
>> Allah commanded us to follow the message
he gave to Prophet Muhammad.
>> Oh my gosh, bro. So, first of all, let
me let me let me ask you this. Let me
ask you this. Let me ask you this. Let
me ask you this. When the verse tells
you to believe in the Quran, can you
believe in the Quran without ever
reading it?
>> Without even reading it.
>> Yeah. Can I believe in the Quran? Can I
follow the Quran without ever reading it
or seeing it?
>> Now you are mixing it. There is
difference between believe and follow.
So which one are you talking about?
>> Both. Can I believe and follow the Quran
without ever reading it?
>> Yes.
>> What?
>> Yes. You you asked me to explain. Okay.
Now, thank you. For example, Allah
revealed the Quran to Prophet Muhammad
and I believe Prophet Muhammad is
following the Quran. If I practice,
>> how do you know if you've never How do
you know if you've never read it? You
don't know anything about Muhammad. How
do you know?
>> No, if Prophet Muhammad if we live
together and I see how he practice is
how [laughter] he did so definitely I am
following the Quran
>> and I believe it is from God. Oh, I'm
asking you. You right now, you can you
follow can you follow the Quran without
ever reading it or seeing it in 2025?
Bro, we ain't talking about the seventh
century.
>> I can't I can't follow the Quran without
reading it.
>> All right. Thank you. Can you follow the
Torah and the Injio without ever reading
it?
>> Did Allah told us to follow the Torah?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Here we go once again. Uh give me
uh give me uh uh uh chapter 5 verse 28.
48.
>> Yeah.
>> 48. No. 68. I think 68. You're right.
You're right. You're right. All right.
Come.
[clears throat]
>> Note, we are talking about to follow. We
are not talking about belief.
>> All right. Yeah. Yeah. Follow. Yeah.
>> Right. Right. Right. All right. I got
it. So, this is Serea 5 68. It says,
"Say, oh people of the scripture, you
have nothing to stand on until you
observe." Uhoh. Till you observe Uh-oh.
The Torah. The what? The Torah. The
what? The Torah. And what else? And the
Gospel.
Okay. Read. And that which has been
revealed to you from your Lord. So he's
saying you got to observe the Torah.
That's right. The Gospel.
>> That's right.
>> And the [laughter] Quran.
>> That's right. Uhoh. Is that three books?
That's three books.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that one book? That's three.
>> That's three. 1 + 1 + ONE. THREE.
>> NOW, now let me explain. You don't even
understand what you are reading.
>> Yeah.
>> We have many ways where Allah address
some people. Whenever Allah want to talk
about those who came before prophet
those who follow the previous prophet
Allah ref refer to him to them as people
of the scripture
>> okay what did he tell but what did he
tell them to do
>> what did he tell them to do
>> I'm talking that I'm telling you that we
Muslims we are if want to tell if want
to talk to us he will say oh you who
have believed but if you if you want to
talk to those who have been following
the previous prophet He will say, "Oh
you, oh people of the scripture." Now he
is talking to the people of the
scripture, not us.
>> What did he tell them to do?
>> Not we believers.
>> He told them them, not us. He told them
to uphold to follow the Torah, not us.
>> Oh wow. Wow.
>> Now, why would he tell people to uphold
and follow the Torah and the
>> Because the message is for them, not us.
>> The message. But didn't your garage just
tell you that you got to believe in
these messages, bro?
>> Wait, wait. Now, let me He
can't stand. He can't stand that Quran.
>> He hate the Quran, man.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Does the verse reverse
to all people of the scripture or not?
>> Yes.
>> As Allah ever address the followers of
Muhammad as people of the scripture in
the Quran?
>> I don't know. That's a good question.
I'm asking the previous verse 346
that says you must believe in all of
those scriptures.
>> We have to believe not to follow between
believe and follow. That's what I'm
saying.
>> How do you believe in a book? How how do
you believe in the Quran?
>> We believe in Quran is different from
follow the Quran. How
>> you said that already. How how Okay, you
said that already. I'm trying to figure
out where your head is at. How do you
believe in the Quran then?
>> How do you believe in the Quran? What
does it what does it mean to believe in
the Quran?
>> To believe in the Quran is that you just
only believe that Allah revealed a book
to Muhammad and the book is from Allah.
That is you have to see [laughter] it.
You have to read it.
>> Yes.
>> That means you believe in Quran to
follow it. You have to read it. So, so
to be clear, my friend, so you're saying
that when the verse says for everyone to
believe in all of the scriptures, the
Torah, the Gospel, the Quran, the
Psalms, all of it, it doesn't mean that
we have to follow all these scriptures.
Like for the Jews and Christians, for
example, they only have to believe in
the Quran that it was revealed from
Allah. They don't have to follow the
Quran. Is that right?
>> Allow to them to follow the Quran.
>> I'm sorry.
>> They must follow the Quran because the
Quran is the is the final testament.
>> No, no. entire what? See, this is why
this is why I'm getting I'm I'm getting
confused.
>> So, you made a distinction between
believing in the book and following the
book.
>> So, when it says believe in the
scriptures, the Torah, the Gospel, the
Psalms, and the Quran for the Jews and
Christians,
>> they are told to believe in the Quran,
but they're not told, they don't have to
follow it. They just have to believe
that it's from Allah. Right.
>> Yes.
>> So, they don't have to.
>> They were told to follow it. To believe
it. They were told to believe
>> another place Allah told them to follow
it.
>> Okay. Where where does it say that?
Where does it say that that Allah says
for the Christian now?
>> Where in 5 verse 62 that you just quoted
>> where where does it
say you have nothing?
>> It says you have nothing to stand on
unless you observe the Torah, the gospel
and that which has been been revealed to
you from your Lord.
>> Yes, that is the Quran.
>> Where does it say? Wait, where does it
say the Quran there? It doesn't say
anything about the Quran. That is the
present message at that time. Note, let
me read it again. It says, "Say, oh
people of the scripture,
>> you are you are on nothing until you
uphold the Torah, the gospel."
>> Mhm.
>> And what has been revealed to you from
[snorts] your Lord,
>> which is
>> now in front of this that is the Quran.
>> Wait is talking about the Quran.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. Where does it
say where does it say the Quran there? I
said and the translator put it in the
front that that is the Quran.
>> Yeah, they put it in parenthesis. I
don't I don't care what they put put in
parenthesis. I only care because I I
know just just respectfully I I resp I
love the Quran. The original Quran at
least, not this corrupted version, but I
I love the original Quran before they
corrupted it and messed it up messed it
all up. In the Quran, it does not say uh
the Quran here at all. Can we agree that
the that it doesn't mention the Quran
here?
>> No. It says that they should follow the
Quran.
>> All right. Tell me where where does it
say because I'm looking at the verse
myself. I also have the Arabic in front
of me. Where does it say the Quran? I
see where it says Torah and Gospel.
Where does it say the Quran?
>> It says that what has been revealed to
you from your Lord.
>> Yeah. How do you Why are you saying that
that's been revealed?
>> Wait, the Torah was revealed to them
from their Lord, right?
>> That is for the past. It already where
does it where does it say anything?
Okay, good. So, what about the Zabore?
The Zabore was revealed to them from
their Lord. Correct.
>> Wait, it's already mentioned the Torah.
>> I said I said the Zabore. I said the
Zabore the Psalms.
>> Yes. Now, after Injil, the only book
that came after Injil is the Quran.
>> Hold on. Where does it say anything
about after or before? It doesn't
mention a time frame here. How do you
know that when it says what is revealed
to you from your Lord is not the Psalms?
Now this is how you will know because
the Torah came before
and when Allah want to say it is he
mentioned the Torah first then in so
which means that it has used the Torah
>> did the did the come before the zabor
the psalms
>> the Torah
>> you okay
>> I can't hear you I don't know your
question [laughter]
>> are you
you you know what the you you know what
the zabor is right
>> yes
>> the psalms when was that no No, no.
Zabur was never the psalm.
>> Oh, what? What's the zabore?
>> Zabur is the revelation that Allah gave
to prophet D.
>> Which is what?
>> Which is revelation.
>> Amen. Well, let me ask him one more
question. One more question. All right.
I just want to see where where this
where this might go. Uh, do you know the
definition of believe?
>> Yes.
>> What is it?
>> To have something in mind that this
thing is h when when
>> Say it. Say it. No. Say it. That this
thing is true.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> All right. So when you believe in the
Quran, you believe that the Quran is
true.
>> Yes. It's from God.
>> So when Allah tells you to believe in
the Quran, he's telling you to believe
that the Quran is true, right?
>> Yes. That the Quran is from him. That
the Quran came from God.
>> Exactly. How on earth could I believe
that the Quran is from him if I don't
read what's inside of it?
>> Yes. No. Even if you don't read it, you
have to believe that.
>> How would I believe? Well, look, look.
What would make me believe that the
Quran is from God and true if I haven't
read it?
>> This is unconditional belief. You just
have to believe.
>> I'm done.
>> That is truly this thing is from God.
>> Appreciate it, bro. Thank you. All
right. Come to Islam. Thank you for
participating, man. We're going to let
some other Muslims come up and show us
how they hate the Quran, but I
appreciate you, man. [snorts]
[laughter]